luego de una reunión que se extendió por
más de tres horas en el Palacio de
Miraflores y que contó con la presencia
de representantes de las carteras de
ambos países en materia de agricultura
ciencia y tecnología petróleo defensa
entre otros ambos mandatarios
suscribieron 13 de 25 acuerdos para
afianzar la relación entre ambos países
el presidente iraní y Ibrahim Racing
dijo además que actualmente el
intercambio comercial entre ambos países
está valorado en tres mil millones de
dólares y que la meta es que Hacienda a
Diez mil millones de dólares y
posteriormente a 20 mil millones les
tocó además que Venezuela eran tienen
intereses y enemigos en común esto
haciendo referencia a Estados Unidos
recordemos que Irán se ha convertido en
uno de los principales aliados de la
administración de Nicolás maduro luego
de las sanciones impuestas por Estados
Unidos en materia petrolera por su parte
Nicolás Maduro dijo que la visita del
presidente iraní la primera
latinoamérica desde que asumió el poder
en agosto 2021 se convertía en un hito
histórico y que también pretenden a
fiazar Los lazos en materia de turismo y
que hay un vuelo diario entre Caracas y
Terán en momentos en que Venezuela
prácticamente no tiene mayor conexión
aérea con el resto de los países tras
visitar Venezuela el mandatario iraní
viajará a Cuba en Nicaragua